[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
let's bring in our favorite sean
salisbury morning host of the sean
salisbury show on sports talk 790
in houston sean what do you make of this
chatter as they like to say
that russell wilson is maybe available
or on the market dan first of all i was
great to be on with you
if when anybody talked about trading for
me it would have been for an apple and a
roadmap you know what i mean now we got
three and four and five first rounders
it's amazing then you start to think
about head coaches and quarterbacks and
how they're tied to it and when that
starts to go
sour carson wins doug peterson because
they're tied together when you're
winning the head coach
quarterback everything's great right
we're kicking butt everything's good
start to go south and everybody's like
well they're tied so the coach starts to
say what's wrong with my quarterback
we saw it in the rams with goff and
mcvay and now
and in philly and possibly here but not
because the coach here in houston but
with this russ wilson pete carroll thing
we've heard talk of a little bit of
strife and
you know and when that happens you start
to wonder three first i think they'd be
nuts dan
there's not a guy i mean when you talk
about the three best not named
homes in the league that you get assets
for right today
rogers watson wilson why would you trade
why would you trade the core your
franchise i mean he's the guy that makes
him go now
they need some help he's obviously can't
get him to a super bowl without some
good defense and the rest of it but
i wouldn't even entertain it that being
said we get guys now that are a little
unhappy and things aren't going well
if somebody called me up or if somebody
said that russ wilson could be had for
three number ones
and like let's say minnesota or new
england wanted him offered three
if i was that team and i knew that they
would give him away for three ones
i'd crawl 10 miles over broken glass for
that i i would
i think it's absurd why work all this
quarterback talk in the league
that we want to give away the guy that
you got to go find anyway
i i seattle would be absolutely nuts now
if they're in a whole rebuilding phase
fine
you're not going to find a guy on the
market right now that you're going to
get
that's going to give you anywhere near
the chance russ wilson does
now the texans have said that desean
watson's not available
the seahawks haven't said anything about
russell wilson
right but it feels like deshawn watson's
going to be traded
and i don't think russ is going to be
traded by seattle
what is if they're not taking offers
you know it's weird that it's public
that they're not taking offers like how
did it become
public that they're not taking offers
right unless they want to continue to
get offers
right dad right and nothing's negotiable
right
sure it isn't right all of a sudden
somebody calls say how about five first
rounders and a couple starters
well okay it just all of a sudden became
we're taking phone calls
dan it's going to be impossible for them
while they may not be now
you know darn well when they're sitting
in a room casario and
the guy who apparently has all power in
jack easterby and cal mcnair
that they're saying we may not be taking
calls but we got to start to consider
that option because while i would not
trade him if i was a gm there we would
never been in this situation
and i would exhaust every opportunity
which they're not doing to see
exhaust to find out desean let me hear
you
what is your concern about this can it
be fixed and then i'd ask him again can
it be fixed and until the point where i
wore out the can it be fixed
then yes you have to field calls and dan
that's going to become more urgent than
then than not why because you've got to
start to feel those calls if you're
going to trade him and you're not going
to play
lying in the sand hardball before the
draft because you want to go draft the
guys you want right with those assets
that
the jets or the dolphins are going to
give you so while they may not be
fielding calls i'll
guarantee you they're keeping a journal
this is my opinion of
okay we know what's out there so while
they may not be now it doesn't say
they're never going to
and i still yet to hear anybody pound
the death saying don't
call us watson's not available do you
think he's
traded is he traded before the start of
the season i would have said now for me
i wouldn't do it dan the more i think
about this and the more that
the the the length continues to lengthen
out and there's no
conversation and i don't know if if kali
can get
to him or nick casaro i think this is
deeper with the easter bee and cal
mcnair thing
and as long as they're there there i
don't think watson's coming back now i
would
i think you're nuts to trade him but dan
there's going to come a point a breaking
point where the fracture turns into
shattered glass
and i think you're gonna have to and if
desean just says he's not gonna do it
i don't know if you can take the risk or
wait until august to say hey
we'll challenge him on this and if
somebody's gonna offer you four ones and
three players
you obviously have to consider it and
then that team's gonna have to feel the
punch to the gut so bad
that their franchise is gutted and
they're in a rebuilding process
and it's gonna take them three or four
years to win even with watson
i wondered about this and i don't have
confirmation i tried to find it out last
night
that the bears weren't in on carson once
they didn't even make an offer
reportedly
they need a quarterback the bears to me
are a sneaky destination for desean
watson i know we talk about carolina and
we throw out the jets and
if i'm the bears you missed him once
don't miss him again and you got a
chance to clean up after mitchell
trubisky and you get the guy that you
want or you should have taken in in the
beginning and look i
i don't i don't have anything that would
tell me this
other than logic and they did not make
an offer for carson wentz
and watson's better than carson winston
and common sense you're right you don't
have
any insight on this but common sense
would say that's inside enough right
this would be the most gifted
quarterback and i couldn't agree with
you more
in chicago's history and it's not just
based on potential potential there's
production with watson
as well and he's 25 and you got him
under contract for the next handful of
years
there is no doubt dan and he here's
what's what's interesting about
the situation what watson brings instant
i mean it instantly makes them a
not only a viable threat in in their
division but a viable threat
all across the league and in the nfc
because now you've got a guy who doesn't
have to load everybody on his back every
single week and carry the defense that
can get off
the field and you're right when you
missed out on a guy like this you say
okay and i'm with the sean mcvay
approach dan
i don't care about winning the trades i
care about now listen am i sure
that the 18th or 19th or 24th or 15th
pick of the draft
is going to give me what watson is no
i'm not and the one thing what are we
always saying about the bears i'm
talking about every year
can we get a quarterback can we and i do
i need to go down the list of them can
we get a quarterback can we get a
quarterback we got this
and they've never had it so if you've
never had it
why don't you go do one thing that gives
you a chance to get it if you think you
can get watson
make them an offer they can't refuse and
give you the one thing you haven't had
in decades that you want a super bowl
with mac but
great defense all these things and this
guy trust me is not gonna let you down
as a quarterback he's just not
and if the chicago bears were wise they
would actually fly
beat down the door at kirby here in
houston and try to beg them
to listen to an offer there's no doubt
it's a sneaky and maybe pittsburgh
sneaky depending on the ben
roethlisberger dead cap money
but if you're desean watson i would
think you'd want to be traded to a
winner
that gives you a chance to win
immediately as opposed to have to go and
rebuild in five years from now
maybe not be in a super bowl because
you're playing for the jets chicago is a
sneaky one to me dan and shouldn't be
sneaky it should be about as subtle as a
punch to the face if you're the bears
talking to sean salsberry former nfl
quarterback host of the sean salisbury
show
in houston the dak prescott situation
you know it's
franchise tag day at least the start of
this here and
i wonder if jerry jones is gonna roll
the dice again and say
let me see what you got for one more
year you're coming back from you know
the ankle injury
and i'm i can pay you decent money
and then we can find out if we want to
do a long-term contract or franchise you
again after that but
give me the logic with the cowboys here
with dak prescott
there is none in my opinion and i love
jerry jones dan
but this would have already been done
listen he's been
until this year and he's going to come
back from this injury just fine
dak will i promise you what what more do
you need to see you wanted stats he gave
you stats
uh he is he's i loved him when he came
out i i thought he was i think i had him
as the second best player in
at that position in the draft and i
think he he fits
off the field he can make every throw
he's accurate he's tough his durability
was
beautiful until unfortunate injury this
year dan i i i would sign him
i wouldn't even mess with this because i
always say this i got a guy who believes
a franchise quarterback
what's the other option what's the other
option
okay i like andy dalton but stop i mean
what's the option you want to go out
while sam darnold may end up being a
star in this league well
i have that guy once again i just don't
understand
you work as a general manager a coach in
a front office or jerry jones your whole
career
to find that guy he got one with troy
aikman if you get a second one
and and romo was a good player too not
everybody can be the packers or the
49ers with those guys
you're lucky if you get one of them and
i just don't understand what you're
looking for
the grass isn't greener i got news for
you dak prescott's back and playing on
that team
they're a playoff team and dak prescott
is a top 10 top 12
quarterback in this league top ten i
would pay him i wouldn't even mess with
it
but i think jerry jones i think he
stumbled into something he loves the
game
no i think jerry jones stumbled into
something
because let's say that comes back he's
not great
i haven't given him that long-term
contract they go seven and nine they
don't make the playoffs they change
their coach
you know jerry this wasn't by design
right
because you know they this they could
have done this two years ago and
probably got him at a bargain
and but this is where we are right now
and jerry jones may go
i didn't plan on this but if dax not dak
and we we're not great then
i don't have to pay him and i'm going to
get a new coach in here and you know
we'll start it again what if he is great
dan
you know what he ends up may if he let's
say he's great they go ten and six and
but then you pay yes but you pay right
and then you pay him
between watson and mahomes money right
yeah he's gonna get 45 million dollars a
year
right and guaranteed like 80 of it right
yeah so he and you're taking the risk
like they all do and jerry's done that
plenty of times but dan i'm just
thinking for the stability of a
franchise
and for what you want going forward and
a guy who's been a model citizen players
love him people love him
he's a competitor he's tough and people
say well he's not a numbers guy well
i saw him throw for what 5 000 yards he
this is a really really good player and
i always say
if this isn't one what's my option you
want cam newton instead of dak prescott
no i i respect cam but no i don't
and you even i heard you guys talk about
darnold over over
prescott no dak prescott is that guy
and he may not be mahomes we always want
to compare everybody mahomes how many is
there
it's mahomes okay so stop it the rest of
them are
guys that are falling into place in the
watson and the rogers and if you can get
that elite player who's
a top seven top eight player you don't
let him go especially at the hardest
position
to find that guy and that you've worked
your whole life to get him i
i love dak prescott and i think the
dallas cowboys would be out of their
friggin minds
if they don't sign him to a long-term
deal and if they want to if they want to
play with fire
watch him go throw for 5 000 yards and
win 10 or 11 games
and then he's going to go crack him for
about 45 mil can cam newton still be a
starter
i think he can with the with a team dan
that that doesn't have a solid starter
and got to have a little luck
um meaning you know fully healthy a
place where there's a quarterback that's
not
stable he's not going in and going to
beat out carson wentz he's not going to
go
beat out whoever if it's zach wilson or
somebody in new york
can you have him as a backup uh that's
that all depends on him
it all depends on where he had his
maturity in the league can he accept
when that opportunity presents itself
that i'll be ready to take advantage of
it
or do you have to roll him in and and
say it's your job until you lose it or
keep it
i would think that that's probably the
the latter is the one that you'd go
you'd say well if he
if it's even we'll start cam newton the
key is at what point in his career with
his body being up in a tremendous career
does he get to the point dan where he
says i can accept this but i'm going to
stay ready to be the starter if you are
going to start him it's a one-year
contract
on a team that's probably not very good
and you're going to give him one more
chance to say
go light it up and prove what you got
for 16 games
i think he's still a viable option but i
don't think he's a franchise guy that's
going to make a huge difference in your
franchise as a starter
did you ever root for the starter to get
injured when you were on the sidelines
as the backup
no dan but i can tell you this and it's
in people that aren't transparent about
this
i was fortunate that i was in rooms with
great guys and great players like
wade and jim mcmahon and warren moon and
and and
rich gan in that group wherever i was
because you love mo
there's nothing worse than hating the
guy that you're competing right i hate
this guy you're dropping back at
practice
now mcmahon never practiced he would
just make me do all the training camp
and then knew he was going to start he'd
laugh he'd be sweats on he'd be laughing
say hey kid get out there my shoulder's
a little sore
yeah from tilting to 12 ounces you clown
but i loved him for it
but dan i i i don't think you ever
wished it but it's human nature to say
you know i'd love us to win this game
but man if if
his shoulder had a little tendonitis or
if he threw three picks and we still won
that'd be pretty cool
but no you don't root for that because
you don't want that guy doing that to
you
but human nature and competition says
well it'd be kind of nice to
you know nothing serious but man if that
turf toe kicked in for two weeks
where i could go there and play did you
ever not want to go into a game
uh let's see yes i'll tell you a story
we're playing cleveland browns it's my
second year in the league i'm with the
colts we won the division
we're at the mistake by the lake dan
it's freezing i'm telling you i'm
freezing it's like
zero degrees i got that big jacket on
with a hoodie and i think it's my second
year in the league i hadn't played much
i'm like and jack trudeau was a good
player was in
i get on with greg briner our
quarterback coach i get on the headset
with him i said we're getting our
our com our butt handed to us by
cleveland in a playoff game first round
and you're going to love this i'll try
to go quick i know you got a break and
so
i i'm sitting there like it's about four
or five minutes to go in the game
and greg bryce said man brian's i don't
want to go in this game man we're
getting our butt kicked it's too cold
it'll take me an hour and then you get
like four warm-up tosses no sooner do i
say that
jack trudeau gets destroyed in the
pocket so i got to go in i got my hair i
got my nice mullet working for tv
i warm up like five throws i'm 24 25
years old 23 so i mean i'm
ready to go i go out there we hit a few
throws and then i call an audible like
an idiot at the line of scrimmage billy
brooks couldn't hear it
i throw a curl route he runs a corner
frank minifield picks it off dan
starts working his way down down and don
crickey and bob trumpy are on the call
and i'm going to tell you why i say that
so minifield's working his way down
minnie's about
five seven and 145 pounds dripping wet
and a pro bowl stud
so i'm thinking to myself literally as
i'm working there somebody tackle him
somebody tackle him at about the three
yard line nobody's tackled his ass and
i'm the one who's got to jump in there
so what's he do i'm standing straight up
he puts his helmet between my
number my one and three drives me into
the end zone and cabbage patches over me
and they score again so i gotta come
back out for the next series so the day
later i'm back in indianapolis season's
over i'm walking through the mall i go
into a foot locker to get christmas
gifts to take home
on that tv you know on foot locker they
used to run highlights and dan
i'll i promise you i walk in there and i
hear bob trump be saying
oh it's intercepted salisbury i mean
they're talking the second i walk in it
shows me
getting cabbage patched on by frank
minifield
so right then and there so yes dan at
that point in time i said
hell no got i got you uh paulie you got
sean's stats in that browns game
yeah he was one for six with 15 yards at
a pick yes
yes and we hit one i missed one down the
middle on a cold to albert bentley
and i i was i didn't fall out till and
then you go into cleveland locker room
and the shower waters up to your thigh
three guys to one locker you know it was
the old school one and i loved it but
yeah dan it was one of those where i'm
like i knew going in that this isn't
where i wanted to be and then i'll be
damned if i'm not walking through
the mall and all bob trumpy and don
cricky are telling me
and that's the one play we see and i'm
like i'm done
i'm out let me out of all of it so yeah
but i never rooted for a guy to get hurt
you usually root for your partner
but you you didn't have a problem if
every now and then you could get in in
the third quarter to make a few throws
unless it's a playoff game against
cleveland where you throw a pick and don
crickey tells you about it
and bob trumpy that was a bad day dan
thank you bud
i appreciate it let me extend it good to
talk to you sean salisbury
i feel like i'm a therapist sometimes
i'll just let it out uh host of the sean
salisbury show on sports talk 790 in
houston